[Music]
Nancy Lieberman former WNBA player and
coach joined the Kings in 2015 as an
assistant coach joining us a courtesy
the Continental Tire Coaches Corner
hi Nance how are you today hi my friend
how are you I'm doing great how many
games did you play for the Washington
Generals against the Globetrotters in in
88 89 I'd say 200 games we were oh and
200 and it was a very debilitating for
us but it was a show and if I could have
stolen the ball and gone in for a layup
I was reminded the rest are paid by the
Trotters were you told not to do it and
like you had to know what each skit was
we knew this kid it's a show the Trotter
is at that time got 66 potential points
a game on show plays so at the same time
on the clock every game you knew it was
a show play if they made it that was
great if they missed it in between that
you played real basketball and at that
time the generals were younger and
better than their trotters who was the
best player you played against when the
Globetrotters oh let's see 20 Sanders
were still pretty good
Osborne he played with Michael Thompson
at Minnesota there was neck piece no but
these guys were getting a little long in
the tooth so none of them were really
young it was kind of some older guys but
not the heroes that we know of what is
your official title with the Sacramento
Kings assistant coach okay hello and
you've been there since 2015 yes this is
my second year with them what is the
role that you play on a day-to-day basis
so when you know when George hired me
and Vlad a last year what happened was
you go in there you're breaking down
film you're putting player personnel
together
you you kind of morphed into who you get
assigned with it's just kind of a
natural type of thing what players like
hypothetically last year you know Omri
Casspi Rondo guys like that were the
guys who were assigned to me and it was
my job you know to make sure that they
had all the the film the game plan you
were showing him the good things that
they were doing you walked through some
of the bad things that they had to make
corrections on and you know it's like
even at Summer League when you're
working with you know your draft picks
this this year's summer league we had
Willie cauley-stein and we had scow
Labiche a we had you know Malachi
Richardson and some of Isaiah cousins so
you're trying to develop guys but the
relationships are really important do
they listen to you oh yeah yeah I mean I
think think about this of the fortune
500 companies Dan 24 of them are females
these guys just if you can help get them
to the next level that's all they care
about so many of these guys have been
raised by their mothers strong women
impact for women in their life you know
this movement we have that Adam silver
is so tremendously brilliant and and
forward thinking about when I was hired
by the Mavs Donnie Nelson in in 2010 to
be the first head coach of the NBA
d-league
I mean Donnie was in there with two feet
and he that gives you the power to know
and the confidence to know you're your
owner is behind you we made the playoffs
in our first year we sent Antonio
Daniels to the fixers to you know to
coach Collins because that's part of the
deal you have to get
guys to their next level so I coats
these guys for 50 games I know what it's
like and they're very receptive and
people who think that this is not
happening right now you're living in
another day you have mr. Roberts you
know leading the The Players Association
I've been on the board of the NBA RPA
this is my second term as being on their
you know Executive Board I'm on the
board of the the the Basketball Hall of
Fame with Jerry Colangelo the board of
governors they want our input you know
you were respecting me in the 80s when
we were we first met yeah well I I think
basketball is the perfect sport here for
this to happen
you know other you know not the NFL or
Major League Baseball but with
basketball I can show the resume of what
you've done and you played thousands of
games so it's not one of those you never
played the game you didn't play the NBA
it's still the same game that you're
playing and that's why I look at what
Becky Hammon is doing at San Antonio and
what you're doing is if you know how to
play the game and and they and you can
lead people being it being an assistant
coach is different than being a head
coach because there's a lot more that
goes into that and that's where I say we
got to be careful of saying well this
person can be a head coach you can be a
great assistant and not be a great head
coach but I'm all for this opening the
door to say a coach is a coach just like
an official an NBA the referee can be
female I think we'll move on past it
quickly and then I'm gonna judge you on
your merits of winning or losing not
that if you're a female or not well I'm
gonna kind of piggyback on what you're
saying when I got the job being the head
coach here and we made the playoffs in
our first year and the legends have not
made the playoffs Penn I was invited to
the White House and by President Obama
and I had TJ with me and the first thing
he said to me when we met because Nancy
I know I'm black it's normal to me I
just happen to be the President of the
United States you know you're a white
woman coaching men
it's normal for you to play or coach
against them it's not normal for the
outside world and he looked at me as he
was holding my hand he says it's our job
to make it normal now you brought up a
great point not every man or woman
through is going to be in a leadership
capacity where they can be the CEO or
they could be the head coach that's a
unique skill set and you have to be an
amazing communicator among other things
Becky Hammon is a really brilliant coach
she's got great communicative skills
she's so highly respected because I mean
think about her she was in that building
for eight years before coach Popovich
gave her that opportunity I've been
around you know when I'm around the
league and players are coming up to me
in pregame and they're like hey you know
I'd like you to meet my family or can
you meet my girlfriend or my my mom or
you're going into practice and they're
like hey hall-of-famer or legend I kept
telling Ron Butler don't do that because
the guys next to me we're all just
assistant coaches and I'm I cannot take
away Who I am
you hired me and you knew who I was but
I have to also fit in with my brothers
and when you have great advocate like
blah Dee Dee vod's and the backhand and
rick carlisle the president of the the
NBA coaches association you have amazing
advocates that are confident enough to
know that the future is right here with
some people including women do you think
that Popovich is going to set the stage
for Becky Hammon to take over for him I
do I do they have a amazing relationship
this is just my opinion but I think that
Becky is being tutored for success and
he does have a very unique set of
circumstances even even
greater than mine and you know the same
thing with Natalie she's it with the
Clippers
you know she's worked really hard to
gain the trust and the belief of Doc
Rivers our situation in Sacramento is a
little bit you know more fluid because
different coaches it could be a little
bit more difficult for me but that's
okay we just need one and you don't
remember when Becky got the job a couple
years ago and she called me and she was
like man I'm sorry and I'm like shut up
don't be sorry you know she was she was
showing me respect as our friends and as
someone you know who you know she said
had been you know a trailblazer
we're not in a competition we just have
to you know if Jackie Robinson becomes
the first we have failed if nobody else
comes after I'm okay being Larry Doby
I'm okay with being the second but we
need more and they're out there and
these women are coming they're bright
they're building relationships and
they're pouring into the game to learn
so they can coach at the highest levels
can you see this though with women
working on the college level with men's
basketball we've had this conversation
about Pat Summitt late Pat Summitt I
said she could have coached anybody
didn't matter
Tennessee men's basketball would have
benefited from him but why haven't we
seen that with men's college basketball
I can't answer the question but I do
think there are some people out there
that are nervous about it and you know
might be apprehensive and really I don't
know why we're not trying to steal jobs
we're not trying to leapfrog people
we're just saying that if we're
qualified if we've paid our dues we
would like to have the same you know
professional opportunities on the
collegiate level I mean I could coach
them college basketball I could be a
head coach there I could be a head coach
you know one day given the opportunity
you know in the NBA but it's going to be
about someone who
somebody actually like coach Popovich
who I just so admire him and RC Buford
because of how they see things they're
so secure with themselves I mean you see
these guys yeah I see it happening you
know you can't look at somebody like me
or Becky and go oh wow they drive nice
cars or they have men well you know what
we're we're different we we excelled in
our world and we're successful but it
doesn't mean we can't be grinders and
and lead and and we have to know the
power we don't know we have and we have
the power to evoke change and to be that
agents have changed as a culture and I
mean I remember before you know my baby
died Muhammad Ali and you know he's been
my lifelong friend but Muhammad and
Lonnie which sit in their house in
Phoenix and then said Nancy you're gonna
coach me ma
you're gonna coach in the NBA and I was
like well you know I mean I hope and
when it happened it was almost like a
premonition I mean he kept saying to me
saying that to me for years it's going
to happen and it it did and that's where
the work starts
we can't just pat ourselves on the back
and say we're in the NBA we have to
really work hard we can't be just as
good we have to be better than ya and
you can't be satisfied with just being
an assistant coach if if we played 211
right now who wins
I mean oh yeah oh me come on I'm still
sneaky and angry I mean yeah oh you know
when when remember way back in the day
when you stayed at the house in Dallas
yeah you I have to say this you were so
much better stronger than I could have
imagined not a lot of people impressed
me with you know guys will say all the
time you know I played or did this but
you actually could play this game and
you were a lot bigger and stronger than
I thought but I would actually set
myself out and let you play against TJ
your son well I'm not gonna do well
against your son you just played you
know he just graduated from college come
on I know yes 33 the other night against
TCU hey by the way let me be a mom for a
second he just was named to the AP
all-american team yesterday takes after
his dad yep takes after his dad I'm
gonna have to hop off this call now hey
Nancy always great to catch up with you
you're the best thank you for everything
all right Thank You Nancy Lieberman the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience